do you find that whenever I'm you know
scrolling Twitter you know you don't go
on Twitter anymore no I read
downloads you're back on and now I'm
back on I'm weaning myself you know I'm
in that stage where it's like no I don't
need it I'm used to not using it now
yeah but when someone sends a link I'll
open it and then I might as well scroll
a little bit yeah and it's just uh
things are going downhill for me fast I
just I was scrolling some viral like
like some tweet that blew up I was just
scrolling replies and there was a
graphic only fans promotion oh yeah and
I just I don't know
I feel
everyone inevitably like you hit a point
with porn I'm a girl or a guy it was a
woman oh God I was a young woman and
poor porn just becomes like become if
it's just so absurd
her face is covered in semen it's like
and she's like
it's just just on your feed oh it was
just like in the replies like she's like
trying to promote her [__] like it was
like she's trying to tag what people
were talking about like yeah you know
like do you want to see glazed what you
know yeah yeah and you're like whoa
imagine the
like physical manifestation of that of
that like uh interaction like people are
just talking like someone says something
and they're like yeah I don't think
that's what I'm saying yeah do you guys
see Trump's mug shot
everyone's like yeah man I thought it
was pretty funny yeah dude he looked
like this thing they hold up an image of
like a meme or whatever and then some
girl just like walks out of the another
room with a face full of comments like
you should check out my only fans yeah
oh everyone's like okay
I bet
oh
it smells like coconut water in here
does it come smell
um yeah bro like I said yeah it does
have a
it doesn't stink semen or come typically
has a faint smell caused by a mixture of
chemicals such as citric acid and
calcium it may also smell slightly sweet
as it contains fructose a strong fishy
odor might stem from an infection
imagine about like the semen smell and
you're like dude it smells like fish
yeah there's always tuna all the time
I saw this Tick Tock or something that
was like girls can always tell that a
dude has jerked off
oh how because they can like smell it
really uh yeah how I honestly am curious
as to if that's true interesting
because I just think it'd be a classic
thing like dudes all along are like
thinking that we're just getting away
with it but we're just dumb you know and
girls are just like I [__] know you
jerked off in the shower this morning
this is your you know yeah you're
walking your wife just walks by don't
get the drain pregnant
[Laughter]
my shower never sometimes Elena will
kind of jokingly be like you beaten off
in here okay I laugh I go absolutely not
that's like our shower it's pretty much
flat oh okay okay and it's like tiles
the only reason you're not doing this
just like the com Logistics I mean
yeah dude I'm I'm pretty like otherwise
I [__] would be no yeah I'm
definitely about convenience yeah yeah
I if dude I'm not [__]
yeah well I was gonna say it's tiled
so if I like I had to explain this to
her because I'm like
I'm like you don't understand come
like she's she's never beat off so she
doesn't get like dealing with it okay
yeah so
I laughed and said if I'm if I'm jacking
off in here it's it's got to be like a
sorry go ahead it's got to be in like a
like a tissue or something like this is
the least beat-offable shower because
you have to like it's flat it's Sweet
Child yeah no bro it'll get in like the
grooves I'm gonna be down there with a
toothbrush like all right get in there
get in there
and then then like she has tons of hair
so that [__] just like it hangs at the
top of the drain yeah so there's a it'd
just be a just be a pancake there
I'm not dealing whacking it is like I've
done it yeah who cares like at this
point hey I'm done yeah I'm kind of done
like I've been kind of done whacking
I've jerked off all you can really you
know
there's nothing else
like
who cares dude
who cares I'm gonna come yeah seriously
oh cool yeah yeah that's fun it's the
dumbest [__] ever
[__] off it takes seven minutes and
you're [__] tired you ruined your day
yeah what is the point yeah that's true
for seven minutes you're like [__] man
and then for the subsequent hours you're
like wait what did you say to who yeah
no and there's regret too yeah there's
definitely regret yeah it's the most
especially when you get like older
you're like what the [__] am I doing
yeah that's what that's what that's what
the previous two hours or like the
preceding two hours are just like what
the [__]
don't jerk off yeah yeah I just like
drop it off his for your 20s it really
is
durkin's for the 20s man that's it for
this one all right we're gonna go jack
off now yeah
turkey and I was really so stupid that's
so stupid it's so stupid
what was this you're looking at your
phone yeah
she's like it's [__] oh it's 10 a.m
hell no hell no I'm a morning person
absolutely I know you are you're crazy
that's when I do everything bro you're
crazy
I don't do [__] at night
beating off at 7am
that is a wild hour to be yacking it man
unless you're a construction worker so
why'd you say it ruins your day then
what time are you doing it at if you do
it before five at you know but seven is
wild I think three or four is weirder PM
yes why
because that's like I don't know like
you're about to sit down for dinner
that's like turn down that's [__]
weird yeah yeah yeah we have a
reservation at five okay
[Laughter]
resume
wake up we're [__] we're late sorry
sorry
are you hungry I don't know what the
[__] I am you know I'm just filled with
regrets yeah
wait who am I
yeah the 22 year old yeah
bro I'm [__] I'm a Nut right here
and then I'm gonna go to class and learn
about Christianity yeah oh my God you
know
crazy oh my God I'm gonna come yeah you
and everyone else man
you and everyone else
yeah what do you think it's all about
you yeah
cool man this is your or you're reaching
climax cool this is me watching porn I'm
gonna come oh wow yeah yeah somebody put
on a [__]
people are gonna come hoorah
nobody cares yeah
then I started crying no one cares when
I come huh no one cares and I [__]
come
that's why I don't jerk off because I'm
I'm mostly upset that no no one pays
attention to me when I come